-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
And we really do hope that
you're all doing well tonight,
collectively.
And, if even one of you
isn't doing well,
well, the evening's ruined
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
The Senate voted yesterday
to block the For the Peopl
voting rights bill,
but not until they got their
voting paperwork in order.
"Let's see.
I got my license, passport
tax returns,
high school yearbook.
Okay. I think I'm ready
for my riddle."
All 50 Senate Republicans
voted yesterday
to block the For the Peopl
voting rights bill,
but they did have
a counteroffer.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Mike Le
said, in an interview yesterda
with Fox News host Sean Hannity,
that the For the People
voting rights act was
"written in hell
by the devil himself,"
which is also what it says
on the poster for "F9."
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that it will likely fall short
of its goal of vaccinating 70%
of U.S. adults by July 4th
but at least the announcemen
will be spectacular.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Anthony Fauci said yesterday
that the Delta variant
of the coronavirus is
"unquestionably
more transmissible
than other common variants
of COVID-19."
Alright, I feel like,
as a treat,
we should let Fauci
announce some good news.
Doesn't even have to be
science-based.
A second season of...
[ As Fauci ]
Mare's back, everybody.
We're so excited.
Just something, so that,
when he shows up on TV,
we aren't immediately like
"Now what?
Did the COVID bat have babies?
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Dr. Anthony Fauci said yesterday
that the Delta variant
of the coronavirus is
"unquestionably
more transmissible
than other common variants
of COVID-19."
Unfortunately,
it was tough to hear him
over the Foo Fighters.
[ Laughter ]
New York held its Democratic
mayoral primary yesterday,
but, due to the city's use
of rank choice voting,
it will be several weeks
before a winner is
formally declared.
Said Eric Adams, "Ugh!
I got to hang around the cit
for several weeks?!"
A trade group representing
U.S. airlines this week
called on the Justice Department
to impose stricter punishments
on unruly passengers,
up to and including
middle seats.
[ Laughter ]
In honor of actress
Meryl Streep's
72nd birthday yesterday,
fans changed New York City's
72nd Street Subway Station
to say "72nd Streep,"
and then Streep won
another Oscar
for her reaction to that news.
"Oh, my God!
This is such an honor."
In honor of Cinema Week,
AMC Theaters
is offering customers
an all-you-can-eat popcorn dea
and an all-you-can-stand
nacho deal.
The amusement park at New York's
Coney Island next month
will unveil its new,
custom-made,
68-foot tall roller coaster,
the Phoenix,
though, if you really want
a thrill at Coney Island,
get in the water.
[ Laughter ]
In a letter to the court,
a woman who was charged
with participating in the
January attack on the Capito
told the judge that she learne
the error of her ways
by watching the movie
"Schindler's List,"
which, she said,
"was hard to watch."
"Okay, rude!"
said Steven Spielberg.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, today was
National Pink Day,
thanks to yet another
gender reveal gone wrong.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.